here's my new plane same graph but
instead of thinking about distance in
time which is just one specific specific
example these axes literally could be
anything right so let's go back to the
way we normally call the Cartesian plane
we normally call this guy X so that it
can indicate anything this guy we would
normally call Y but I'm going to say
let's also call it f of X we're
representing using all of that function
notation which we developed earlier in
the year you've got this vertical thing
is going to be dependent on this
horizontal thing okay now if I've got
these as my labels when I think about
this same right angle triangle into you
maybe you want to just for the sake of
your own diagram make it a little bit
bigger there before when we look at this
right angle triangle and we look at
working out the gradient which is like
what's the slant of this hypotenuse
right what I need to know is what is the
run
what is the rise and then I just do a
division that's how I normally do this
for gradient right so let's actually get
a little more specific here let's pick a
point and X value and I'll literally
call that x value X if I went forward a
little bit okay I'm gonna move a little
bit to the right
okay the distance that I'm going to
travel for reasons that will become a
little more obvious later I'm gonna call
this distance here H H for height by the
way if that distance is H then what will
the X corner of this this further this
right to most value here be you've
started from X you've gone forward this
little bit what will the value be here X
plus h does that make sense if H were 1
for example then this would be X plus 1
you've moved over just a little bit ok
so there's an X value there's an x value
a little bit further along I can use
each of these to work out the Y values
right because these will give me the
rise now this is f of X this blue
function right so if you put in X what Y
value should you get out of that it
should be f of X whatever whatever your
F is right it could be a trig function
or it could be a parabola
right what about this value up here this
function value comes from a different
horizontal coordinate right so when you
put this value in what will you get up
here f of X plus h very nice assurance
so this is all of the numbers are all of
the values that I need to work out my
rise and my run let's think about it
together rise this is how far vertically
you went right so you want to start from
like the top and subtract the bottom
like a hundred take away zero but in
this case it's not 100 or zero this is
my top value and this is my bottom one
are you okay with that so I'm going to
do top takeaway bottom it looks a bit
gross f of X plus h takeaway what's the
one vote f of X it does look a bit gross
but that's because I'm trying to
describe this could be any function at
all okay what's the run that's the rise
what's the run I don't have to do any
calculation don't have already done it
think the run is how wide this triangle
is right and we started off by saying
what if you went over this little
distance which I called H right so
therefore the run is just this value
here H so I've got a rise I've got a run
now what we're doing is we're
calculating the difference between two
points in space and then we're dividing
between them that's what gives us
gradient but because we're now going to
be thinking about remember I showed you
that animation before right we're
thinking about changing this not just
between one point and another one but
between any points I could put X
anywhere I like so instead of calling
this the gradient it's gonna get a bit
of a fancier name it's still the same
thing but we're going to be using this
phrase a little more frequently because
we're working out the difference between
two things this is something to do with
difference so that's the first word in
this phrase and then once you've got
your rise your run what operation do we
use again we're going to we're not gonna
multiply we're not going to add we're
going to divide right does anyone know
what's think back to like polynomials
what's the name of the thing the answer
when you divide two things it's not a
product it's not a sum it's a question
thank you very much
this is what we call the difference
quotient okay it's what happens when you
divide rise over right it's the same
thing as gradient but we're trying to be
a little more specific on what we're
calculating here okay so this difference
question is the rise which is this guy
take away the Run which is this guy okay
put a big box around that guy we're
going to be using this a fair bit the
difference quotient and here's what
we're going to be using it with I want
you to look closely at this graph that
I've given you
thank you uses these what does that look
like to you what do you see
seems like a parabola good guess okay so
this is a parabola I want you to look
even more closely
could you make a decent guess as to what
parabola it is sorry just just have a
look at the information you got there
have a guess could you work out its
equation x - hmm so for a second I'm
just gonna we are gonna work out this
equation I promise you can all work it
out but I'm just gonna let that question
sit in the back of your mind for a
little bit I promise you've got enough
information you can work out the
equation I haven't heard anyone say it
yet but you can keep on think about it
okay here's what I want us to work out
you're gonna take some time to do this
okay all this diagram I want us to work
out the difference questions and you're
welcome to work together on this because
there's a fair bit of work to do I want
us to work out the difference quotients
at different places on this graph so for
example over here if we start on the
leftmost area here if I wanted to work
out actually now let's start let's start
over here first because we were thinking
about rising things it's a bit easier
right
if I think about Point starting here and
going over to here I've put on gridlines
there to make it a bit easier for you
okay I can draw a right angle triangle
that fits on to these corners let me see
if I can make it nice and obvious for
you can you guys see that can you make
it out yep good so I've got a
right-angled triangle here here's my
right angle triangle like so and I can
work out I can literally see the rise is
going to be one two
three that's how high it goes what's the
run one so my difference question in
this case I'm just gonna write
difference question it's going to be 3
over 1 which is 3 now you can go ahead
and you can calculate the difference
question all the way along the graph not
just for this one but you could do like
say I'll put in a different color so you
can see a little more clearly you can
work out this one you can work out this
one here you could work out here's
another one over here
except this time the rise is not going
to be 3 the rise is going to be negative
3 in this case because you're dropping
aren't you right this is a bolt deciding
everyone's everyone needs a chance I'm
gonna run backwards for a little while
ok so you can see here I can work out
the difference question all the way
along and I'd like you to do it every
veldt value that you can on this graph
can you do that for me go ahead work
together with the person next to you do
blocks of 1 and write down your results
in like a table in your book so you can
write down the difference questions for
this function and then I also like you
like these are blocks of 1 right I know
it's going to seem like why would I do
this but I promise is a reason I'd also
like you to do blocks of 2 so for
example I will show you one right now if
I started up here at y equals 5 up there
Q see my orange dot in the top left hand
corner if I went over 2 units 2 units
right
actually this Griego another way it's
gonna look like this isn't it all the
way down to there do you see that it is
a big one ok so you would get a
different difference quotient say all
right a different difference quotient
out of calculating this and I want you
to get those values as well okay so do
it for runs of 1 do it for runs of 2 and
then I want you to compare those values
give you guys a few minutes to work on
that